they differ
as his name by the way yes that's the
thing and the All-Star break game
Lillard the fourth leading scorer in the
NBA and here he goes firing Away part of
that 75th Anniversary team named last
year in NBA history
and again it's not necessarily how you
start but you want to start to find a
rhythm
and here we we think this is too close
for James spot oh he ain't got one of
those you got it
yeah he I feel like he's about to go
right past 25.
and here comes his money rack yep right
this side of the Court
yeah so that's six points alone from the
sorry range
[Music]
this is his money record he's got to
make up right here here he goes 25 is
the one to beat
your hair now here we go pressure here
here we go
23. need the money
[Music]
balloon
oh he knocked out a former champ in
buddy Hill
your chances just dropped to 50 it
surely did it surely did August 67. look
at him he made his last four shots
we got that one to go then the story
range ball so six points alone on those
two shots yeah think about that huge
it's easy money oh man
all over the concentration nothing but
net all I'm missing is this go to your
wrist Dame
here's buddy Hill's reaction like my if
I'd have made one of those Starry rain
shots
[Applause]
Damien Lillard I'm gonna give up boys
credit just for being in the finals
we have had no three uh Point champion
from the Trailblazers until tonight
first ever
when there's a lot of first before
Portland series yep
that's what I was waiting on right there
directions
Weber State
the uniform he's wearing tonight that
was the the first school and really the
only school that recruited him out of
high school in Oakland California they
played in Oakland he went to Ogden Utah
and now he plays in Oregon really makes
you question basketball Talent
evaluators all right
please direct your attention to Center
Court and welcome head of marketing for
starring Michael Smith here to present
the 2023 Starry Three-Point Contest
trophy to Damian Lillard from the
Portland Trailblazers
thank you
so his third appearance in this contest
is the charm
Ed with NBA
aunties
Dame Lillard we know your path Oakland
to Ogden to Oregon you went to college
30 minutes away from here how much more
special is it to win your first
three-point title with the college in
the background I mean it makes it that
much more special uh you know I did it
two times before they say the third
time's a charm and I'm happy that it
happened here so it's a perfect
situation I'm happy I could do it in my
home coming back here to Utah you are
the Portland Trailblazers
you are the first three-point champion
in the history of the franchise we know
you're one of the greatest three-point
Shooters to ever lace them up what does
this mean for you to have this on your
Mansions I think all the best Shooters
in the history of our game uh most of
them have one of these and so like I
said to be in this competition a few
times and not have one
um I just wanted to give it get it done
at least one time so I'm happy I got it
now I can retire from it you tough give
it up for your guy The Starry
Three-Point Contest Champion Dave
Lillard Lillard right now on a pace to
set an all-time single season Blazers
scoring record